[Music]
hey man
um
i guess it's been a year
that's kind of weird
just trying to think of what i was going
to say
i was trying to think about
whether this year was as involved as
last year
and uh
yeah i was having
trouble thinking about because i did a
lot this year definitely
but i can't say i did as much i don't
think i'll ever say i did as much in a
year as uh we did together so
i don't know if that's a good
metric of comparison that's not why i'm
here
you know
for some reason in my head always when i
think of unisons is like the cups the
cup stacking i think of like you cryptid
style
like with the cuffs it was that was uh
yeah that's good
i miss it
yeah i missed a lot
yeah i just miss it
i think it was
just about the
coolest thing i've ever done
and just hearing how people say how
meaningful
lunasanus was to
them when they saw it and when they saw
it get deleted and how that like
impacted them i've had so many people
talk to me about it and to say
what a what a like
inspiration it was and i you know
and all that is true it's always true i
think that's like what we wanted to say
and we did say it and we said it well
but also i just
i just make us making the videos
i've done like
a tv show this year and i did i did
space and it was great and it was hard
and it was hard work but also you know
oh this wasn't like when it's honest
oh
anyway i'm not here to get mopey
now you're taking i'm here to just like
you know tell you i'm
you know
i miss it but i'm doing good you know
i learned a lot
both during and after it i learned a lot
and i think it took a year of you know
reflecting to get to the point where i
really appreciated
every part of it
yeah
all right
i'll miss it
miss you
i'll uh
i'll never forget and uh
i'm gonna be coming back every year so
just uh
don't think i'll ever forgotten
okay
all right
you